So this morning we're going to start talking about Edmund Burke and the anti
enlightenment.
Um,
and one prefatory note is that,
um,
when thinking about political theory as opposed to every day political argument,
I think it's very important not to get hung up on labels such as left wing or
right wing or liberal or conservative.
Uh,
and I think the occasion of beginning to speak about Burke is a good moment to
make this point.
After all,
I think be fair to say that before you walked into this course,
you would have,
if you had looked down in the syllabus and somebody had said,
who is the most radical thinker on this syllabus?
Most of the,
most of you would've picked out marks.
Um,
but as we've seen,
Mark's is actually a footnote to the enlightenment marks is not,
he's not somebody who engages in a radical departure from the ideas that would
develop by,
um,
lock.
And the other thing is that shaped the main ideas of the enlightenment.
Burke on the other hand is generally thought of as a conservative politically
and indeed he was a conservative politically,
but philosophically he's a much more radical thinker then marks was,
he is somebody who a re really goes to the root of accepted assumptions in his
critical questioning.
Um,
Burke completely rejects the enlightenment project as I have described it to you
today.
Um,
let me say a little bit about who he was.
He was born in 18,
29.
Uh,
so that makes him,
I mean 1729,
sorry,
gave him a hundred years there.
He was born in 17,
29 a quarter of a century after locked died.
Um,
and the main work for which he's most known there,
his reflections on the revolution in France was published in 1790 almost to
almost exactly a century after.
I'm actually more like 110 years after Locke's second treaties.
Why should say it was published a hundred years after,
but it was written 110 years after because we now know that Locke wrote the
second treaties in the,
in the early 1680s.
Um,
but what motivated Burke to write his reflections on the French revolution was
the,
the s appalling carnage that eventually resulted from the French revolution.
Uh,
the,
you know,
the French Revolution was not planned,
uh,
as a revolution.
It was really street riots that escalated in,
in,
in Paris,
but escalated to the point of the complete destruction of the whole society.
Uh,
the inauguration of a massive Chera,
uh,
which,
um,
uh,
Paul Burke.
And,
um,
so he wrote this,
this,
uh,
what started out as a pamphlet but,
but became this very famous book on the reflections on the revolution in France.
And that becomes a basis of Berks outlook.
Um,
he wasn't a professional scholar or academic.
He was actually a,
uh,
public,
person.
He was,
he would eventually become a member of parliament,
um,
and has some things to say about democratic representation that I will come back
to,
uh,
when we get to the theory of democracy.
But at the time he wrote the reflections on the revolution in France,
which is what I had you read excerpts from today.
Um,
he was mainly preoccupied with what had happened.
What had transpired across the channel,
uh,
in 1789 and he was in particular,
um,
concerned to establish against people like Richard Price is one of the people
who engages there.
That's that 1789 was in any sense a logical follow on of 1688 in England,
1688,
of course,
when we had the revolution in England,
the Glorious Revolution of 1688,
um,
when,
when William was put on the throne,
which,
which locked offended,
um,
uh,
but from Burke's point of view,
that was a minor palace affair,
not a fundamental or radical revolution.
And in this sense,
uh,
Locke's view,
I'm sorry,
um,
Burke's view of the English revolution.
For those of you who are historians here,
you might be interested in now is very much at odds with the big new book called
1688 just recently published by Professor Pincus in the history department here.
A very interesting book,
um,
which argues that 1688 was a much more radical break with the past.
Then,
uh,
people thought at the time and suddenly then Burke thought,
because Burke thought that 1688 was not a radical break with the past where 1789
in France was a radical break with the past.
And I think that,
um,
another thing to say before we get into the particulars of Berks view is that
unlike everybody else you've read in this course,
Burke Renae does not have a theory of politics.
He does not have,
um,
a set of premises that you can lay out,
conclusions to which he wants to get.
And then chains of reasoning that get him from a to B from the premises to the
conclusion.
There is no theory of politics in Berg.
There's no this,
you know,
we think it would con we thought got universalize it rd.
Um,
lock,
we talk about this commitment to unit two principles of scientific certainty.
Um,
Burke has,
rather than a theory,
he has an attitude or a disposition and outlook.
Um,
and that outlook is,
it is informed at first and foremost by extreme distrust,
not only off science,
but if anybody who claims to have,
um,
scientific knowledge,
he thinks that human society is way too complicated
for us ever to get completely to the bottom off
that we're kind of,
uh,
carried along on a wave of very complicated history that we understand only
dimly if at all.
And that that's not going to change.
The human condition is a condition first and foremost of fumbling in the dark.
Okay.
He says,
uh,
just to give you a flavor of this,
the science of constituting a Commonwealth or renovating it or reforming it is
like every other Eric experimental science not to be taught a priore.
So here you can see a complete resistance to the,
the logic or reasoning,
uh,
that drove Hobbes and Locke and thinking about the structure of mathematics.
Uh,
and a system of axioms of the sword.
Bentham,
uh,
tried to come up with no says burn noise,
a short experience that can instruct us in that practical science because the
real effects of moral causes are not always immediate,
but that which in the first instance is prejudicial may be excellent in its
remoter operation.
So when we think we see something bad,
it might be having a good effect and it's excellence may arise even from the ill
effects of producers at the beginning.
The reverse also happens and very plausible schemes with very pleasing
commencements of often have often shameful and lamentable conclusions in states
that are often,
there are often some obscure and almost late and causes things which appear at
first view of little moment on which a very great part of its prosperity or
adversity may essentially depend.
So,
um,
okay,
the world is fundamentally mysterious and murky and things that look good might
have bad consequences.
Things that look bad might have good consequences.
The effects of our actions are going to be a realized in the distant future in
ways that we can't possibly imagine.
Um,
and so that being the case,
the most important
characteristic of thinking about politics is caution.
We should be cautious.
The science of government being they're so practical and itself and intended for
such practical purposes,
a matter which requires experience and even more experienced than any person can
gain in his whole life.
Okay.
However,
sagacious and observing he may be.
It is with infinite caution that any man or to venture upon pulling down an
edifice which has answered in any tolerable bulled degree for ages,
the common purposes of society or on building it up again without having models
and patterns of approved utility before his eyes.
So what they did in the French Revolution was the antithesis of what Burke
recommends because they swept everything away and decided to build again.
Tabula Rasa.
Burke is deeply suspicious of all attempts to do that,
and he thinks they'll end in disaster.
Um,
because the people who undertake them will not know what they're doing and even
more dangerous.
They're not smart enough to know how dumb they are.
They're not smart enough to realize that they really do not know what they're
doing.
They're not smart enough to understand that they will unleash forces which they
will not be able to control.
So Burke is in that sense,
a conservative who thinks about social change in a very cautious and incremental
way.
He's not a reactionary in the sense of being someone who's opposed to all
change.
He's a conservative,
right?
One of the,
I think one of the nice definitions of conservatism in Berks sense was actually
put forward by Sir Robert Peel in the 19th century when he said he defined
conservatism as changing what you have to in order to conserve what you can,
changing what you have to in order to conserve what you can as distinct from a
reactionary view,
which could be just flat resistance to all change.
Um,
now,
uh,
of course this idea of conservatism as valuing tradition is very different from
the libertarian conservatism of Robert Nozick that we looked at,
uh,
Olia in the course.
Um,
the,
the libertarian conservatism of Robert Nozick is anti-statist antigovernment and
resistance to authority being imposed on you.
And it's the notion of libertarian conservatism.
Burke is a traditionalist conservative.
He thinks that tradition is the core of human experience.
And he thinks whatever wisdom we have about politics is embedded in the
traditions that we have inherited.
They have served us over centuries.
This is his view,
writing at the end of the 18th century.
They have served us for centuries.
They have evolved in a glazed steel way.
As I said,
people make accommodations to,
uh,
change,
but only in order to conserve the inherited system of norms,
practices,
and beliefs and institutions that we reproduce going forward.
So that's the sense in which it's a conservative tradition to conserve the basic
meaning of the word conserv conservative.
Okay.
And so science is a really bad idea when applied to political and social
arrangements because there isn't scientific knowledge and anybody who claims to
have it is either a Charlotte chain or a fool
habs both.
Um,
and so that's his,
as I said,
he doesn't have a theory because he's skeptical of the very possibility of
having a theory.
He thinks,
um,
we should,
as Clint Eastwood says,
Ah,
I've forgotten in which movie it is.
I think a fistful of dollars,
maybe a man's got to know his limitations,
right?
Are you feeling lucky?
A man's got to know his limitations.
Um,
Burke thinks that in spades.
He thinks we have to understand that our,
our grasp of the human condition is very limited and it's gonna stay that way.
So on the first about two prongs of the enlightenment and Devaa,
he's completely out of sympathy.
Now what about the second,
what about the commitment to this idea of the importance of individual rights?
We saw how this developed in initially in locks formulation,
um,
in a theological way when lock argued that God created us with the capacity
behave in a godlike fashion in the world.
Each individual,
uh,
is the bearer of the capacity to create things and therefore have rights over
his or her own creation.
In Locke's view,
we're all equal.
We're equal in God's sight.
He creates us all equally and,
um,
we're all,
uh,
also equal in a sense,
very important for lock that no earthly power has the authority to tell us what
the scripture says.
Each person must do it for themselves and when they disagree and they have to
either find a mechanism to manage their disagreement,
um,
or if they can't look for their reward in the next life,
but basically each individual is sovereign over themself.
And,
uh,
that's where modern doctrines of individual rights come from.
We saw how that played out with the workmanship ideal.
Uh,
the mill's harm principle,
um,
all the way down through Nozick and Rawls.
Bentham has,
I'm sorry,
Burke has a very,
very different view of the idea of rights.
They are,
first of all,
they are inherited.
They're not the product of reason or,
um,
any contrived theoretical formulations.
They're inherited.
You want to observe that from revolutions,
society,
from that,
from revolution society to the Magna Carta.
It has been the uniform policy of our constitution to claim and assert our
liberties as an entailed inheritance do derive to us from our forefathers and to
be true can submit it to posterity as an estate specially belonging to the
people of this kingdom without any reference whatsoever to any other more
general or prior.
Right by this means our constitution preserves a unity in so great at diversity
of its parts.
We have an inheritable crown and inheritable peerage and a House of Commons and
a people inheriting privileges,
franchise and liberties from a long line of ancestors.
So what we think of,
uh,
when we talk about rights for Burke,
first of all,
they're not human rights or natural rights for him.
They are the rights of Englishman.
They're the rights of Englishmen.
They are particular rights that the result of a particular tradition,
the idea that that could be universal rights doesn't make any sense.
It's not an intelligible,
it's not an intelligible question as far as Burke is concerned to us,
say what roles would say,
what rights would we create for all people,
um,
uh,
in some abstract,
setting,
it doesn't make any sense to him.
So it's the rights of Englishman and indeed when Burke Burke was sympathetic to
the American revolution,
not the French revolution,
it was because he thought that the rights of the American colonists as an
Englishman were being violated by the English crown.
And he was also a sympathetic to a home claims for home rule for Ireland.
Again,
on the same sort of basis,
but it's,
it's this entailed inheritance,
what we have,
um,
being born into as a system of rights and obligations that we reproduce into the
future.
And they,
those rights above all are limited
again,
just as how knowledge of the world is limited.
So our rights in a normative sense are limited.
Governments is a contrivance of human wisdom to provide for human wants.
Men have a right that these ones should be provided for by this wisdom among
these once is to be reckoned the want out of civil society have a sufficient
restraint.
Okay.
It's sufficient restraint upon their passions.
We have a right to be restrained,
okay.
Right.
And very different notion than a right to create things of a which we have
authority or right to be restrained.
Society requires not only that the passions of individuals should be subjected,
but that even in the mass and body as well as the individuals,
the inclinations of man should frequently be thwarted.
They're well controlled and their passions brought into subjection.
This can be,
can only be done by a power out of themselves and not in the exercise of its
function subject to that will and to those passions.
Okay.
Which it is,
it's office to bridle and subdue it is this sense of the restraints on men as
well as their liberties.
Okay.
In this sense,
the restraints on men as well as their liberties are to be reckoned among their,
the restraints on man as well as their liberties are to be reckoned among their
rights.
Okay.
But as the liberties and the restrictions vary with time and circumstance and
admit to infinite modifications,
they cannot be settled upon any abstract rule.
Take that John Rawls and nothing is so foolish as to discuss them upon that
principle.
Okay.
So we have a right to be restrained.
We have a right,
most importantly that others are going to be restrained.
Um,
and,
and that our passion should be controlled,
uh,
is something that
yeah,
he insists is an important part of what we should think of under the general
heading of what it is that people have rights to.
One of the first motives to civil society in which becomes one of its
fundamental rules is that no man should it be the judge in his own cores.
By this,
each person has at once divested himself of the first fundamental right of
uncovering rented man.
That is to judge for himself and to assert his own cores.
That's not that different from lock.
That first part,
after all,
lock talks about the state of nature as being exactly a state in which we get to
judge in our own cores,
but for lock,
we give it up in a conditional way,
right?
We never lose the right to revolution.
If society doesn't protect us then,
and that's what he thought was triggered in 1698 books has no,
he abdicates all right to be his own governor.
He inclusively in a great measure,
abandons the right of self defense.
The first law of nature.
Men cannot enjoy the rights of an uncivil and a civil state together
that he may obtain justice.
He gives up his right of determining what it is in what it is in points the most
essential to him that he may secure some liberty.
He makes a surrender and trust of the whole event.
So he's saying,
yeah,
you could do,
you know,
this,
this to some extent has a hobby z and flavor that that Hobbes says,
um,
if we don't have law,
we'll have civil war.
And so we have to give up freedom to authority.
The differences even in Hobbs this formulation,
there's ultimately the,
the recognition that if society does not provide you with protection,
uh,
you have a reasonable basis for resistance and for overthrowing it.
But,
uh,
in Locke's case,
I mean in,
in,
in Berks case,
uh,
he doesn't want to concede even that because we cannot,
once we've made the transition into civil society,
we cannot go bad back.
There's no turning back.
We're,
we are,
uh,
part and parcel of this system of entailed inheritances.
And that is the human condition all the way to the bottom.
Um,
he doesn't reject completely the metaphor of the social contract,
but he makes it indissoluble.
He says,
society is indeed a contract.
Subordinate contracts for or objects of mirror,
occasional interest may be dissolved at pleasure.
If I make an agreement with you have to do something,
we can agree to dissolve our agreement,
but the state ought not to be considered as nothing better than a partnership
agreement in a trade of pepper and coffee,
Calico or tobacco or some other such law concern to be taken up for a little
temporary interest and to be dissolved by the fancy of the parties.
It is to be looked on with other reverence.
It here's the state is to be looked on with other reverence because,
because it is a not a partnership in things subservient only to the gross animal
existence of a temporary and perishable nature.
It is a partnership in all science,
a partnership in know art,
a partnership in every virtue and in all perfection.
As the ends of such a partnership cannot be entertained in many generations.
It becomes a partnership.
Now,
this is the most famous sentence Burke ever wrote.
It becomes a partnership not only between those who are living,
but between those who are living those who are dead and those who are yet to be
born very different idea of the social contract,
right?
Partnership between those who are living,
those who are dead and those who are yet to be born.
Each contract of each particular state is button a clause in the general
primeval contract.
I'll be Turnell society.
So the law is not subject to the will of those.
This is the flat rejection of workmanship,
right?
The law is not subject to will have those who,
who by an obligation above them and infinitely superior bound to submit their
well to that lore.
The munitions municipal corporations of that universal kingdom are not morally
at liberty,
at their pleasure and on the speculations have a contingent improvement holy to
separate and set a under the bonds of their subordinate community and to
dissolve it into an unsocial uncivil,
unconnected chaos of elementary principals.
So
one way of just driving home the,
the radical break here between his thought and the social contract theorists is,
um,
to mention that one of the standard criticisms that often gets made if social
contract theory is,
well,
even if there was a social contract,
you know,
some people think of the adoption of the American constitution as a kind of
social contract after all,
it was ratified by the states.
Actually,
the articles of confederation had said it had to be unanimous,
unanimously ratified and they,
they couldn't get that.
So they changed it to three quarters of the confederacy states.
Still there was an agreement of some sort and it was ratified and so on.
But people often said,
have often said,
well,
so what?
So those people and the an 18th century made an agreement.
I didn't,
what does that got to do with me?
Why should it be binding on subsequent generations?
And that's often been a critique of the idea of the social contract.
Berk turns that reasoning on its head,
right?
He's,
he says,
once we see that this social contract is multigenerational between the,
the,
the dead,
the living and those who are yet to be born,
who are you any given individual?
Who are you to think that you cannot spend it?
What gives you the right
to pull the rug out from under this,
this century's old evolving social contract?
Um,
what gives you the right to take it away from those who haven't even been born
who are part of this?
It turned off,
uh,
eternally even uses the word eternal.
Um,
this a terminally reproducing a social contract.
So it's,
it's a sort of mirror image of the critique which says,
well,
we never made it,
so why should we buy be bound by it?
He says,
ah,
it pre,
it preexisted you and you're going to pre decease it and you don't have the
right,
you don't have the authority to undermine it because any rights you thank you
have are the product of this evolving contract that contained within it.
So society is not subordinate to the individual,
which is the most rock bottom commitment of the workmanship idea.
On the contrary,
the individual is subordinate to society,
right?
Obligations come before rights.
We only get a rights as a consequence of the social arrangements.
MMM.
That gave us our duties as well.
So,
um,
whereas the enlightenment tradition makes the individual agent sort of moral
center of the universe,
this,
um,
God like,
uh,
individual,
creating things over which,
uh,
she,
oh,
he has absolute sovereign control,
uh,
is replaced by the exact mirror image of the idea of an individual subordinate
to inherited community's traditions,
social arrangements,
political institutions,
um,
uh,
to which he or she is ultimately beholden.
If there was a pre collective condition.
It's of no relevance to us now because we can't go back to it.
And any attempt to try look across the English Channel and see what you're going
to get.
That is the Birkin our blog.
Uh,
in a nutshell.
And it is,
as I said,
uh,
the most fundamental critique of the enlightenment it's possible to make.
And this,
even though the enlightenment tradition,
as we've discussed,
the we have,
um,
studied at here was
mmm.
Unfolding in the 17th,
18th,
19th,
and 20th centuries.
This anti enlightenment undertow has always been there as well.
MMM.
And,
uh,
you know,
you could,
not to make the metaphor do too much work,
but you can really think of every wave of advancement in enlightenment thinking
I'm washing down the beach,
uh,
and producing an undertow of resistant resistance and resentment against it.
Uh,
both philosophically and we're going to,
I'm going to start talking in a minute about 20th century Burkey and figures,
uh,
but also politically,
um,
you know,
one story about the rise of fundamentalism and jihadism and,
um,
ethnic separatism,
is this is all part of the,
and the political undertoe
yeah.
Against the current form that the enlightenment a political project is taking,
which is globalization,
a homogenization,
the sort of Mcdonald's effect on the world produces this backlash against
globalization where people affirm,
um,
primordial lucking attachments even though they probably no such thing as a
genuinely primordial one.
Um,
uh,
separatist,
a partial affiliations and allegiances,
connections to doctrines which deny the scientific and rational project of the
enlightenment.
And so just as globalization has been advancing,
we've seen a resurgence of separatist religious,
fundamentalist,
a nationalist and other kinds of identities.
Quite the opposite.
For example,
of what Mark's predicted,
Mark's predicted that things like nationalism,
sectarian identifications would go away.
Uh,
so he,
he and Lenin to,
um,
they thought that as,
as the principles of capitalism diffuse themselves throughout the world,
um,
things like national attachments would go away.
And indeed on the,
on the eve of the first world war,
there was the second communist international where they basically came out and
said to the workers of Europe,
don't get involved in this national awards,
not in your interest.
You have a common class interest across nations,
against
the interests of employers across nations.
And of course,
this fell on completely deaf ears in 1916 the second international pretty much
disintegrated.
And,
and in fact,
you know,
one of the big paradoxes of the 20th century has been the,
the persistence of things like nationalism through the first two world wars.
And then in the,
in the last part of the 20th century,
this resurgence of religious,
uh,
and other forms of traditionalist attachment a that are fundamentally
antithetical to the enlightenment project.
So the enlightenment has always produced reaction and ditto rejection often from
the people who don't benefit from it.
Um,
and it's one of the ways in which I think the proponents of the enlightenment
have always been politically naive.
They've always thought that as modernization and enlightenment diffuses itself
throughout the world,
um,
these kinds of primitive thinking will go away.
Well,
it turns out that they don't.
And so one of the big tasks of political science,
uh,
at the present time is to try and understand why to try and understand,
what the dynamics of,
um,
political affiliation and identity attachment really are.
And so,
um,
that's a Berkey and agenda.
Now,
if you fast forward from Burke to the middle of the 20th century,
I had you read a short piece,
very famous and important piece by Lord Devlin,
who was an English judge like Burke,
someone with Irish origins.
Um,
those some,
a certain amount of,
um,
ethnic ambiguity in both cases that by just how much Irish and that's just how
much English,
but we needed to attain ourselves with that in this course.
Um,
and he was commenting upon something called the Wolfenden report,
um,
which was published in 1959 and by a commission that had been
mmm
yes,
to,
to tell the British parliament what it should do about homosexuality and
prostitution and the welfare and report had said the laws against them should be
repealed.
They should both be legalized on the grounds.
They didn't use these terms,
but,
um,
uh,
this is the basic thought or the term we would use today on the grounds at both
homosexuality and prostitution are victimless crimes.
Um,
they are to use the jargon of a owl owl course,
Paredo superior exchanges.
They have voluntary transactions among consenting adults that don't harm anybody
else.
And,
uh,
of course this was put in a different idiom because it was the 1950s,
but that was essentially the point.
They don't harm anybody.
So it's just traditional prejudice,
bigotry that leads us to outlaw these things.
And we shouldn't do it.
That was what the wolf and didn't report had said and Burkey and the core Lord
Devlin Says No.
Okay.
Anyone,
I don't know how caught up you are in the reading.
Any,
anyone who has read
Burke,
I'm sorry.
Devlin.
Tell us why he thinks,
yeah,
you get,
we need to get you the mind why he thinks,
why is it that Lord Devlin thinks of it,
the back there,
that the mere fact that there's no harm is not enough of a basis for legalizing
homosexual prostitution.
Yeah.
He claims that it's not,
uh,
an an attack against the individual,
but a harm against society.
Okay.
So
what does that mean though?
What you say it's a harm against society.
I mean,
how,
what do you take it?
How do you unpack that in your mind?
Um,
I guess it's a,
maybe an attack against the morals that society tends to agree to.
Yeah.
Well,
agreed.
Let's put brackets around.
Agreed.
It's not clear what we mean by,
but certainly the morals that are there.
Okay.
And where do they come from?
Where did those morals,
I mean,
so we have a moral code that says homosexuality and prostitution are wrong,
but so where does that come?
You know anyone?
Yeah.
Well he put a lot of weight on the basis of religion for driving ones morals.
Correct.
Religion.
An interesting look what he says about it.
Religion,
he says,
uh,
moral San religions are inextricably joined.
The moral standards generally accepted in western civilization being those
belonging to Christianity outside Christendom.
That's a 1950s words.
We don't say Kirsten dim anymore.
Dewey outside Chris and them are the standards derive from other religions
outside Christendom,
other standards derived from other religions.
In England,
we believe in the Christian idea of marriage and therefore adopt monogamy as a
moral principle.
Consequently,
the Christian institution of marriage has to become the basis of family life.
And so part of the structure of our society,
it is there not because it is Christian.
This comes to the point about whether we've agreed it is there not because it is
a Christian.
It got there because it is Christian.
But it remains there because it is built into the house in which we live and
could not be removed without bringing it down.
It's there.
Not because it's Christian.
It got there because Christian as a matter of history,
it was a Christian civilization.
So we have a Christian conception of morality.
But he's not saying
it's true.
He's not saying that Christian set of beliefs about religion is true.
Here's no interest in,
in the question of whether or not it's true.
He's saying here a different society might be glued together by a different
religion,
which would create monogamy.
Um,
it might create polygamy
and that would have its own history and its own system of rights and
institutions,
uh,
and everything that goes with that.
Right?
So
it's,
it's conservative in a sense of affirming tradition,
but not conservative in the sense of saying there are absolute moral values.
Um,
neither Burke nor Devlin ventures any opinion on that subject.
And he's,
they say it's not even really important.
Right.
What's important is that the people and the society believe in these values.
And if the people answer the society don't believe in some system of values as
authoritative,
the society will fall apart.
You can't put together a society just on the basis of interest.
It needs more.
It needs moral glue.
So,
so these,
these folks,
you could say,
when I say they,
they don't really have a theory in a sense that we've looked at theories apple
till now in this course,
it's because you could say,
well,
they're not political theorists.
They're really sort of sociologists,
right?
They're really sociologists of stability is they're saying that it's necessary
for a society to be stable,
that it's held together by this kind of moral glue of authoritative opinion.
Okay.
So when you say to Lord Devlin,
when he's,
when he's defending,
um,
the outlawing of homosexual prostitution,
well,
that's just your bigotry.
His answer wouldn't be to deny that it's in some absolute sense,
an irrational position.
But he would say every society needs it's bigotry.
Every society needs its prejudices.
Okay.
And so he doesn't appeal to rationality.
Buddy does appeal to what he calls reasonableness.
And what is reasonable?
This,
it's basically the system of beliefs as he puts it of the man on the clap.
I'm omnibus.
We might today say the woman on the a train.
Okay.
Reading The New York Post,
right.
The,
the,
the prejudices of the average person.
That is the basic yardstick.
And if the average person
is appalled by
some practices,
then they should be illegal.
And that's the beginning of the end of it.
So what about that?
You know,
and you could,
you could fast forward with it since he talks about homosexuality and what we
call gay rights today,
if you look at the American trajectory,
1986 this came up
okay.
Before the Supreme Court in a case called Bowers versus Hardwick,
and,
and they essentially took,
took the Burke Devlin position that assists a state should be allowed to outlaw
homosexuality because most people find it deplorable.
Yeah.
Couple of years ago,
it came back to the court and they said,
well,
mores have evolved enough since 1986 that we're going to overturn Bowers versus
Hardwick.
Very Birkin,
very right that they're following the man on the clap,
him omnibus.
They're following the woman on the trains,
prejudices,
beliefs,
and values.
And that's
okay
as it should be.
What about that,
how many people find this appealing?
Only to how many people find it an appealing.
Okay.
So we,
we,
we still have at least half fine decided,
right.
What's unappealing about it?
Yeah.
Take,
take the microphone.
According to his perspective,
we might still have a system of slavery in this country.
According to this perspective.
We would still have slavery in this country.
Well,
uh,
I think he wouldn't concede the point that quickly.
He would say what I just said about Bowers versus Hardwick,
that,
uh,
if,
if the views of the man on the clap and omnibus evolve enough,
then we can recognize change.
Um,
now you might want to not accept that because,
um,
what if they haven't,
you know,
before?
Um,
yeah.
Okay.
You refute that.
I,
I would just say that,
uh,
our morals and our ideas of what is right and wrong are shaped by,
the,
the systems that we were born into.
And consequently,
I feel like Burke and Devlin system ascribes like a great deal of value to the
moral conceptions at,
at the beginning of society.
And that's like almost leads us
to like a system of status in terms of our morality.
Like there seems to be too much status and no ability to reevaluate given how
our moral systems are shaped.
I think that's right.
And we will pick up with this on,
uh,
on Monday.
But if you think,
if,
if you think that the basic society's structure
is okay,
you're likely to find this doctrine appealing.
But if you think the basic structure of the society is deeply on Jast,
then you're likely to be a fronted by this outlaw,
right?
Because one person's reasonable morality is another person's head,
Germany.
And we'll start with that idea next time.